To finance his revolutionary struggle,
the mpa can only count on support
of those who share it.
We do not receive any subsidies from the state
and in fact we only have uh.
Enemies in the big business,
unlike the Zemmour,
Le Pen,
uh or Macron,
who have in fact uh,
no trouble running uh in an election.
Because in fact,
reality,
is that uh.
It costs several hundred
thousands of euros to introduce themselves uh.
To Europeans.
Obviously,
this uh,
democracy,
it is already uh.
Biaisée in advance.
That's why we turn to you,
young workers.
Because the npa is 1 party of activists,
still in the campaign,
and not only during election periods.
That's precisely why we count well
to make our ideas heard,
uh.
That we could uh,
already defended during the mobilization uh
against pension reform,
uh at the
demonstrations in support of the Palestinian people
or uh against the law of Armane.
We do not run in the European elections
simply to be elected,
but to convince the ideas,
uh.
Communists,
revolutionaries,
and the fact that for uh,
change this system
and uh,
by organizing and fighting together,
and so, uh,
to lead this fight,
we need you,
uh.
Make 1 donation to the npa.
The link is in description
for a world without borders,
nor bosses,
power revolution.